les doy la bienvenida a este programa
especial de cultura en Franz 24 sobre
los artistas frente a la política y la
geopolítica en 2022 dentro de los
acontecimientos que marcaron este año la
guerra en Ucrania sin duda se destaca en
Franz 24 seguimos con mucha atención el
conflicto y las consecuencias para el
mundo artístico del lado ucraniano tal
como del lado ruso ciertos artistas se
quedaron en Ucrania a pesar de los
bombardeos pero muchos huyeron por
razones de seguridad o simplemente para
poder seguir trabajando escuchamos
algunos testimonios
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por supuesto es muy difícil salir al
escenario tu mente está con tus amigos
con tu familia que están en Ucrania
ahora miramos las noticias todo el
tiempo y es muy difícil sonreír y estar
en el escenario y de buen humor y pensar
en tu familia tus parientes que están en
peligro ahora
de esta manera puedo dar más y ayudar a
más gente si tenemos trabajo aquí
también podemos ayudar a la gente que se
queda en Ucrania pero si vengo a Ucrania
nada porque no soy un guerrero no soy un
soldado
puedo hacerlo pero no será demasiado
efectivo
[Aplausos]
no puedo quedarme quieto y hacer mi
trabajo sea cual sea necesito hablar con
la gente necesito hablarles con músico
con palabras pero necesito difundir este
mensaje sobre Ucrania sobre lo que está
pasando allí
[Música]
a veces siento culpa una culpa muy
racional creo que la mayoría de la gente
siente lo mismo cuando sale del país
pero por otro lado entiendes que todo el
mundo tiene que contribuir rendir
homenaje al país
porque como músico lo mejor que puedo
hacer es tocar lo mejor que puedo hacer
es enviar un mensaje tocando música
participando a nivel cultural
[Música]
si tomar una posición puede resultar
natural para los artistas ucranianos la
cuestión se complica para los rusos
constelaciones sanciones y boicots
durante estos nueve primeros meses de la
invasión se puso en la mesa el debate
sobre lo que se puede exigir a un
artista en el caso de esta guerra los
problemas y los riesgos que acompañan
las opiniones disidentes en Rusia son
numerosos incluso cuando un artista ruso
vive afuera del país su familia y ha
llegados pueden estar amenazados y
también nos podemos preguntar Hasta qué
punto y sobre qué principios se puede
aislar a un artista por sus opiniones El
ejemplo reciente del prestigioso teatro
de la escala de Milán en Italia plantea
estos dilemas su director explicó Por
qué eligieron reemplazar a su colega
Ruso
y por qué a pesar de las críticas
mantuvieron la obra de
lo escuchamos
tuvimos que pedir una aclaración al
director ruso Valery y el Jeff lo
hicimos cuatro horas después del
comienzo de la guerra no le pedimos que
hablara en contra de su país no le
pedimos que hablara en contra del
presidente de la república rusa se
conocen desde su juventud pero sí que
hiciera una declaración Clara a favor de
una solución pacífica eso es lo que
queremos Paz armonía
no pudo hacerlo no quiso hacerlo no sé
qué responder Así que le sustituimos
poner herborismo duno en escena es una
decisión que tomamos hace tres años es
imposible cancelar un proyecto así Y por
qué habríamos de hacerlo al hacer Boris
Go down off no hacemos propaganda de
Putin tenemos que ver la diferencia
entre la situación política actual y
Rusia es una gran Obra maestra de la
historia del arte ya lo he dicho No
quiero esconderme cuando lea dostoyevski
o a pushkin Son obras maestras que
respetamos mucho nada en esta producción
va contra Ucrania
cada vez más aislada de occidente Rusia
lanzado una Revolución cultural
conservadora cuyos Pilares son la fe
ortodoxa el patrialismo y la defensa de
la verdad histórica Esto fue la gota que
colmó el vaso para ciertos artistas
rusos sobre todo los que por ser
personas queer ya sufrían la falta de
libertades en Rusia algunos junto
ucranianos fueron en París por el taller
de los artistas en el exilio ahora
buscan rehacer sus vidas en Francia
para ser sincera nunca pensé que
abandonaría Rusia a toda prisa que en
paquetería toda mi vida en una maleta
que huiría lo desconocido pero este
momento llegó era el 24 de febrero
cuando estalló la guerra
toda persona cuerda en Rusia se
preguntaba Qué debo hacer
cuando salí de Rusia sentía aquí en
Francia un gran gran enorme agujero en
mi alma porque solía vivir con la
presión del exterior es como un hábito y
sé cómo vivir con eso pero aquí donde
tengo cierta libertad Simplemente no
sabía qué hacer con esa libertad es como
es como Simplemente no sé qué hacer
[Música]
2022 puso de relieve otro país donde ser
artista puede ser peligroso Irán desde
la muerte de Maza a mini el 16 de
septiembre un movimiento sin precedentes
de protestas estalló en el país con una
represión muy violenta de parte del
gobierno pero sus artistas buscan
amplificar La Voz del pueblo de las
figuras más famosas como el director
asgard faradi y la actriz Gold farani
ácaras menos conocidas como sanas la
bailarina de 31 años se instaló en
Francia en 2019 para seguir una
formación en danza contemporánea sanas
baila ahora en las marchas de
solidaridad con los manifestantes pero
hace ya unos años que utiliza su arte y
sus redes sociales para hablar de los
problemas de Derechos Humanos en su país
desde París y ya nos explicó Por qué
bailar es el compromiso de su vida
cada momento que bailo es político
[Música]
Así que no puedo separar el arte de la
política
cada vez que bailo estoy luchando contra
la ley islámica contra el régimen iraní
Es cierto que empecé a aprender la danza
en Irán y me formé allí mucho
pero todo era secreto clandestino
siempre existía el riesgo de ser
detenido
Como algunos de mis amigos que ya han
sido arrestados por la policía fueron a
la cárcel por el delito de bailar
desde que empecé a bailar nunca fue
realmente para mí o solo como una pasión
es para los iraníes y sigo bailando
porque lo siento como un deber como una
responsabilidad especialmente en este
momento con las manifestaciones
es el deber de todos los artistas
iraníes Ellos
sí invitó a los artistas iraníes que
quizás no hayan empezado a comprometerse
a que lo hagan
caso porque es importante lo que los
artistas podemos hacer con nuestro
instrumento el arte
que utilices eso
con lo que cada uno tenemos en nuestras
manos según nuestras capacidades y
Nuestro camino
a la danza en la pintura en el canto o
en la música
los artistas pueden elegir utilizar sus
voces para defender causas pero también
Durante los momentos de la vida política
de un país como durante las elecciones
presidenciales en Brasil ya habíamos
analizado en este programa Quienes
fueron los cantantes y músicos detrás de
Lula Y si bien esta compañía estuvo
marcada por nuevas estrategias en las
redes sociales para difundir sus
mensajes el historiador Paulo César
Gómez destaca que los artistas se
comprometieron con valores e ideas más
que con hombres políticos y que los
ciudadanos eligieron entre dos modelos
de país un Brasil conservador y otro
progresista
los jóvenes por ejemplo votan por ideas
más que por un partido político más que
por la derecha o por la izquierda
por eso creo que Anita en particular se
dio cuenta de que era necesario promover
ideas y no decir
Estoy por el partido de los trabajadores
estoy por Lula no dijo estamos por la
democracia estamos en el caso de Anita
por los derechos de la mujer por la
sanidad para todos por la educación
todos los valores que normalmente se
asocian a la izquierda
y ahora con la elección de Lula que
asumirá la presidencia el próximo
primero de enero preguntamos también a
Paulo César Gómez lo que se viene en
este futuro mandato para los artistas
por supuesto para el ámbito de la
cultura la situación va a cambiar la
cultura y la educación
en primer lugar porque bolsonaro ha
transformado el Ministerio de cultura en
una secretaría de culturas
lo que es jerárquicamente inferior y
usó la cultura para difundir valores de
extrema derecha racistas también recortó
muchos fondos públicos destinados a la
cultura Así que poco a poco vamos a
empezar de nuevo tenemos que reconstruir
el campo cultural y repensar el lugar
del estado Cómo debe estar presente en
el campo cultural y como primera acción
Lula ha invitado a una cantante y
productora cultural margaret Menéndez
que viene de bahía para ser suministra
de cultura loco que ya apunta en una
dirección diferente a bolsonaro una
mujer negra y que tiene experiencia en
producción cultural Así que esto es muy
importante para Brasil Nos despedimos de
este programa especial con Amelia noche
la última canción de La exitosa drac
Queen brasileña Pablo vitar fue elegida
para cantar el primero de enero durante
la posesión de erula Gracias a ustedes
por su confianza y sigan con nosotros
hay más cultura en France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]
así conmigo